so let me start with Roy Amara
so Roy's argument is that most new
technologies tend to be overestimating
their impact to begin with and then they
get underestimate in the long term
because we get used to them these really
are days of miracle and wonder you
remember that wonderful song by Paul
Simon there are two lines in us what was
it that was considered miraculous back
then slowing down things slow motion and
the long distance call because of course
you used to get interrupted by operators
who tell you long distance calling you
want to hang up and now we think nothing
of calling all over the world
well something similar may be happening
with reading and programming life but
before I unpacked that let's just talk
about telescopes so telescopes were
overestimated originally in their impact
this is one of Galileo's early models
people thought it was going to ruin all
religion so we're not paying that much
attention to telescopes but of course
telescopes launched ten years ago as you
just heard
could take this Volkswagen fly it to the
moon and you could see the lights on
that on that Volkswagen light up on the
moon and that's the kind of resolution
power that allowed you to see little
specks of dust floating around distant
Suns imagine for a second this was a Sun
of billion light years away and you had
a little speck of dust that came in
front of it and that's what detecting an
exoplanet is like and the cool thing is
the telescopes that are now being
launched would allow you to see a single
candle lit on the moon and if you
separated it by one plate you could see
two candles separately at that distance
and that's the kind of resolution that
you need
to begin to image that little speck of
dust as it comes around the Sun and see
if it has a Bluegreen signature and if
it does have a Bluegreen signature it
means that life is common in the
universe the first time you ever see a
Bluegreen signature on a distant planet
it means there's photosynthesis there
there's water there and the chances you
saw the only other planet with
photosynthesis are about zero and that's
a calendar changing event
there's a before-and-after we were alone
the universe forget about the discovery
of whatever continent so as you're
thinking about this we're now beginning
to be able to image most of the universe
and that is a time of miracle and wonder
and we kind of take that for granted
something similar is happening in life
so we're hearing about life in these
little bits and pieces we hear about
CRISPR and we hear about this technology
and we hear about this technology but
the bottom line on life is that life
turns out to be code and life is code is
a really important concept because it
means just in the same way as you can
write a sentence in English or in French
or Chinese just in the same ways you can
copy a sentence just in the same ways
you can edit a sentence just in the same
ways you can print a sentence you're
beginning to be able to do that with
life it means that we're beginning to
learn how to read this language and this
of course is the language that is used
by this orange so how does this orange
execute code it doesn't do it in ones
and zeroes like a computer does it sits
on a tree and one day it does plot and
that means executes a a TCA a G make me
a little root tcga CC make me a little
stem GAC make me some leaves AG C make
me some flowers and then G CAA make me
some more oranges if I edit a sentence
in English on a word processor then what
happens is you can go from this word to
that word if I added something in this
orange and put in GC AAC
using CRISPR something else that you've
heard of
Linda's orange becomes a lemon or it
becomes a grapefruit or it becomes a
tangerine and if I edit one in a
thousand letters you become the person
sitting next to you today be more
careful where you said what's happening
on this stuff is it was really expensive
to begin with it was like long-distance
calls but the cost of this is dropping
50% faster and more as long the first
$200 full genome was announced yesterday
by Veritas and so as you're looking at
these systems it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter and
then it does so let me just give you the
map view of this stuff all right this is
a big discovery there's 23 chromosomes
cool let's now start using a telescope
version but instead of using a telescope
let's use a microscope to zoom in on the
inferior of those chromosomes which is
the Y chromosome it's 1/3 the size of
the X it's recessive and mutant but hey
just a male and these are looking at
this stuff here's kind of a country view
at a 400 base pair resolution level and
then you zoom in to 550 and then is
inland 850 and you can begin to identify
more and more genes as you zoom in and
then use a mine to the state level and
you can begin to tell who's got leukemia
how did they get leukemia what kind of
leukemia do they have what shifted from
what place to what place and then you
zoom into the Google Street View level
so this is what happens if you have
colorectal cancer for a very specific
patient on the letter-by-letter
resolution so what we're doing in the
stuff we're sore gathering information
and just generating enormous amounts of
information this is one largest
databases on the planet that's growing
far faster than we can build computers
to store it you can create some
incredible maps of this stuff you want
to understand the plate and why one
plague is bubonic and the other one was
a different kind of plague and the only
every kind of plate well here's a map of
the plate some are absolutely to humans
some are not I know by the way as you go
to the bottom of this how does it
compare to tuberculosis so this is the
difference between tuberculosis and
various kinds of plagues and you can
play detective with this stuff because
you can take a very specific kind of
cholera affected Haiti and you can look
at which country it came from which
region it came from and probably which
soldier took that from that African
country to Haiti zoom out it's not just
sue me again this is one of the coolest
maps that were done by human beats so
what they've done is they've taken all
the genetic information they have about
all the species and they've put a tree
of life on a single page that you can
zoom in and out so this is what came
first how did it diversify how did it
branch how large is that genome on a
single page it's kind of the universe of
life on earth and it's being constantly
updated and completed and so as you're
looking up this stuff the really
important change is the old biology used
to be reactive used to have a lot of
biologists that had microscopes and they
have magnifying glasses they're out
observing animals the new biology is
proactive you don't just observe stuff
you make stuff that's a really big
change because it allowed us to do
things like this and I know you're
really excited by this picture it only
took us four years and 40 million
dollars to be able to take this picture
and what we did as we took the full gene
code out of a cell not a gene not two
genes the full gene code out of a cell
built a completely new gene code
inserted it into the cell figured out a
way to have the cell execute that code
and built a completely new species so
this is the world's first synthetic
life-form and so what do you do with
this stuff well this stuff is going to
change the world let me give you three
short
turn friends in terms of how it's going
to change the world the first is we're
gonna see a new Industrial Revolution
and actually mean that literally so in
the same way as Switzerland and Germany
and Britain change the world with
machines like the one you see in this
Lobby created power in the same way as
CERN is changing the world using new
instruments and our concept of the
universe programmable life-forms are
also going to change the world because
once you can program cells in the same
ways you program your computer chip then
you can make almost anything so your
computer chip can produce photographs
can produce music can produce film can
produce love letters can press
spreadsheets it's just ones and zeros
flowing through there if you can flow a
TCG's through cells then the software
makes its own hardware which means it
scales very quickly no matter how what
happens if you leave your cell phone by
your bedside you will not have a billion
cell phones in the morning but if you do
that with living organisms you can make
this stuff at a very large scale one of
the things you can do is you can start
producing close to carbon neutral fuels
on a commercial scale by 2025 which
we're doing with Exxon but you can also
substitute for agricultural lands
instead of having 100 hectares to make
oils or to make proteins you can make it
in these vats of ten or a hundred times
the productivity per hectare or you can
store information or you can make all
the world's vaccines and those three
bets or you can store most of the
information that's held at CERN in those
three baths DNA is a really powerful
information storage device second turn
you're beginning to see the rise of
theoretical biology so medical school
departments are one of most conservative
places on earth the way they teach
anatomy is similar the way they taught
Anatomy a hundred years ago
welcome student here's your cadaver
one of the things medical schools are
not good at is creating new departments
which is why this is so unusual so Issac
Cohan has now created a department based
on informatics data knowledge at Harvard
Medical School and in a sense what's
beginning to happen is biology is
beginning to get enough data that it can
begin to follow the steps of physics
which used to be observational physics
and experimental physicists and then
start creating theoretical biology well
that's what you're beginning to see
because you have so many medical records
because you have so much data about
people because you've got their genomes
because you've got their virals because
you've got their microbiomes and as this
information stacks you can begin to make
predictions a third thing is happening
is this is coming to the consumer so you
too can get your gene sequenced and this
is beginning to create companies like
23andme and companies like 23andme are
gonna be giving you more and more and
more data not just about your relatives
but about you and your body and that's
gonna compare stuff and it's going to
compare self across time and these are
going to become very large databases but
it's also beginning to affect a series
of other businesses in unexpected ways
normally when you advertise something
you really don't want the consumer to
take your advertisement into the
bathroom to pee on unless of course if
you're IKEA because when you rip this
out of the magazine and you pee on it
it'll turn blue if you're pregnant and
they'll give you a discount on your crep
right so when I say consumer empowerment
and this is spreading beyond biotech I
actually really mean that we're now
beginning to produce at Synthetic
Genomics desktop printers that allow you
to design a cell print a cell execute
the program on the cell we can now print
vaccines real-time as an airplane takes
off before it lands
we're shipping 78 of these machines this
year this is not theoretical biology
this is printing biology let me talk
about two long-term trends that are
coming at you over a longer time period
the first one is we're starting to
redesign species and you've heard about
that right we're redesigning trees we're
redesigning flowers redesigning yogurt
cheese whatever else you want and that
of course brings up the interesting
question how and when should we redesign
humans and a lot of us think oh no we
never want to redesign humans unless of
course if your child has a Huntington's
gene and is condemned to death or a less
of your passing on a cystic fibrosis
gene in which case you don't just want
to redesign yourself you want to
redesign your children and their
children and these are complicated
debates and they're gonna happen in real
time I'll give you one current example
Orla debates going on with the National
Academies today is you have the power to
put a gene drive into mosquitoes so that
you will kill all the malaria carrying
mosquitoes now some people say that's
going to affect the environment in an
extreme way don't do it other people say
you know this is one of the things
that's killing millions of people yearly
who are you to tell me but I can't save
the kids in my country and why is this
debate so complicated because as soon as
you let this loose in Brazil or in
southern Florida mosquitoes don't
respect walls you're making a decision
for the world when you put a gene drive
into the air this wonderful man won a
Nobel Prize after won a Nobel Prize he's
been worrying about how did life get
started on this planet and how likely is
it that it's in other places so what
he's been doing is he's going throughout
his graduate students and saying this
graduate students
build me life but don't use any modern
chemicals or instruments build me stuff
that was here three billion years ago
you can't use lasers you can't use this
you can't use that he gave me a vial of
what he's built about three weeks ago
what does he built he's built basically
what looked like soap bubbles that are
made out of lipids he's built a
precursor of RNA he's had the precursor
of the RNA be absorbed by the cell and
then he's had the cells divided we may
not be that far call it a decade maybe
two decades from generating life from
scratch out of proto communities second
long-term friend we've been living and
are living through the digital age we're
starting to live through the age of the
genome and biology and CRISPR and
synthetic biology and all of that is
going to merge into the age of the brain
so we're getting to the point where we
can rebuild most of our body parts in
the same ways if you break a bone or
burn your skin that regrows we're
beginning to learn how to regrow our
tracheas how to regrow our bladders both
of those have been implanted in humans
Tony Atala is working on 32 different
organs but the core is going to be this
because this is you and the rest is just
packaging nobody's gonna live beyond 120
130 hundred 40 years unless if we fix
this and that's the most interesting
challenge that's the next frontier along
with how common is life in the universe
where did we come from and questions
like that let me end this with an
apocryphal quote from Einstein
it's your choice you can focus on the
bad you can focus on the scary and
certainly there's a lot of scary out
there but use 10% of your brain to focus
on that or maybe 20% or maybe 30% but
just remember we really are living in an
age of miracle and wonder we're lucky to
be alive today we're lucky to see the
stuff we're lucky to be able to interact
with folks like the folks who are
building all the stuff in this room so
thank you to all of you for all you do